judging by the fans erection everyone is
really excited to know that the captain
jack spyro is back
hi everybody
how are you guys
johnny depp has won a rare victory as he
attempts to discover whether his ex-wife
amber heard has carried out her promised
donation of her seven million dollar
divorce settlement many of his
supporters including celebrities have
come out to congratulate him on his win
let me give you a hug i love you my
brother see you soon
what was going on and how did johnny win
let me break it down for you amber heard
and johnny depp have been appearing
across all media outlets due to their
never-ending legal battles their
marriage has brought the two stars more
misfortune than anything else amber and
johnny's relationship began in early
2012 and by 2015 they were already
married however their marriage was
filled with so much turmoil that by may
2016 barely one year since they got
married amber heard filed for divorce
which was accompanied by a restraining
order against the oscar-nominated actor
when getting the restraining order amber
claimed that depp had been abusive
during their relationship at the time of
filing for the divorce he had thrown his
phone at her leaving her with bruises
among other allegations later on all the
accusations made by amber were proved
false by a police spokesman who
testified to having responded to her
call and found that no crime had taken
place depp also denied all the
accusations made by amber and claimed
that she was attempting to secure a
premature financial resolution by
alleging abuse after a lot of back and
forth between the two actors a seven
million dollar settlement was reached in
august 2016 when they finalized their
divorce the aquaman actress then pledged
to donate the money to the american
civil liberties union and children's
hospital los angeles however amber never
fulfilled her promise to donate the
money according to depp's lawyer andrew
caldcott heard's claim about the
donation was a calculated and
manipulative lie that tipped the scales
against depth from the very beginning
and now a new york court seems to agree
with this because in recent developments
a new york judge has ruled in favor of
johnny's request to determine whether
amber followed through with donating
part of her divorce settlement to the
american civil liberties union the 35
year old actress had previously pledged
to donate her entire settlement to both
the american civil liberties union also
known as the aclu and the children's
hospital los angeles in 2017. a hearing
transcript obtained by people magazine
reveals that heard's attorney elaine
bredhoff said that her client is still
planning to donate one half of her total
settlement to the aclu and the other
half to chla she has also claimed that
herd has already made the first payment
toward the pledges we have produced the
documents from the aclu on how much she
has she has always said she fully
intends to continue to give the full 7
million but she can't do it yet she will
do it when she can but she has given a
significant amount to both bredhoff
added depp was not convinced that the
aquaman actress has given the amount to
aclu and went on to request that the
organization provide documentation of
amber's donation the organization did
not reveal any details of amber's
donation which then led depp to sue them
in may this suit was to force the
non-profit organization to reveal
whether hurd had made the donations the
court papers show that depp respectfully
requested the court to enter an order
directing aclu witnesses to fully comply
to the subpoenas according to johnny
depp these documents will go a long way
in helping his case against amber heard
for her 2018 op-ed piece in the
washington post getting these documents
would have also played a huge role in
johnny's libel case against the sun
since the judge ruled in favor of amber
heard due to her alleged pledges to
charity this means that if depp would
have been able to prove that her did not
make any donations then he would have
had a better chance at winning the libel
case this win means so much not only to
johnny but also all the people who stood
behind him in all this some of the
people who showed support to johnny
include jk rowling who chose to cast
johnny depp as grindelwald in the
fantastic beasts franchise a decision
that most people weren't happy about at
the time this was during the first days
of his court case where johnny was
widely believed to be a wb
despite this jk rowling saw something in
johnny depp that made her cast him and
she defended him throughout the first
two films this was when johnny depp was
receiving the most backlash from fans
rowling said that she was doing what
both amber and johnny depp had wanted
during their joint settlement to get on
with their lives rowling continued to
say that based on our understanding of
the circumstances the filmmakers and i
are not only comfortable sticking out
our original casting but genuinely happy
to have johnny playing a major character
in the movies he was right from the
beginning
uh
i we go back such a long way it was um i
couldn't really imagine doing it without
him
sia was also quick to show her
unwavering support for johnny the 45
year old singer took to twitter to
defend and show support for the 57 year
old actor she posted a tweet that read
just showing my public support for
johnny depp i mean i'd love to see him
get clean and stop with the jewelry but
he is clearly the victim after hearing
those tapes sia then went on to share
the recording of amber heard and johnny
depp arguing in which amber heard is
confessing to hitting johnny depp across
the face cia not only voiced her opinion
concerning the matter but also went
ahead to throw some shade at amber heard
in elon musk by revealing that elon was
the one who gave amber the 7 million she
supposedly donated from her divorce
settlement as if that wasn't enough sia
went on to ask elon to stop protecting
amber since she will never get the help
she needs if he stays silent winona
ryder johnny depp's ex-fiance was among
the people who were not only shocked by
the abuse allegations made by amber
heard but also in full support of johnny
winona ryder was engaged to johnny depp
in the 1990s for a four-year period
during this time winona claimed that
johnny was a loving man and that she
even considered him her best friend she
went on to say
i knew johnny very well years ago we
were together as a couple for four years
and i counted him as my best friend and
as close to me as family i count our
relationship as one of the most
significant relationships of my life
winona went on to say that amber's
experience with johnny depp is so wildly
different from her own that she was
shocked confused and upset when she
heard the allegations johnny's
ex-girlfriend vanessa parody was also
quick to jump to johnny's defense
vanessa was summoned to the trial
concerning the father of her children
and amber heard and without a doubt the
word she spoke carried a lot of weight
here is what she said i've known johnny
for more than 25 years we've been
partners for 14 years and we raised our
two children together through all these
years i've known johnny to be a kind
attentive generous and non-violent
person and father he was never violent
or abusive to me vanessa also said that
she was aware of these allegations which
amber heard has publicly accused johnny
deppa for more than four years now but
insisted that those accusations were
inconsistent with the true johnny she
knew parody also said that she never
experienced violence or physical abuse
from johnny depp she also acknowledged
that these accusations have caused harm
to depp's career johnny's daughter lily
rose has come out multiple times in
support of her father including posting
an article about how amber called the
police on johnny depp stating that he
abused her but there was no evidence of
that happening at all she later on
posted pictures of the father and
daughter together stating her love for
her father and that there is no way he
is the way they are projecting him to be
my dad is the sweetest most loving
person i know he's been nothing but a
wonderful father to my little brother
and i and everyone who knows him would
say the same she wrote on instagram this
is just the first win for johnny depp
but if it continues this way he might
end up winning other court cases and
amber will end up facing some serious
jail time for her crimes
now i would love to know what you think
about the recent twist in johnny's court
case will he finally get the justice he
deserves let us know in the comment
section below
[Music]